yeah it's great to be here I'm good to
see all of you I am going to talk about
machine learning for creativity
interaction and inclusion and I'm not
going to assume any particular machine
learning expertise or creative
technology expertise here so I'm going
to start out really just with an
introduction to the space I'm gonna show
you some of the work that I've done in
this space and then really give you a
tour through some of my research
findings over the last 10 years
examining how machine learning can be
useful to human creators and why and how
to make it more usable and useful and
then I'm going to finish up with some
current work which is also a bit more
speculative around using machine
learning for promoting inclusion and
also improving inclusion within machine
learning so let's get going so machine
learning most of you probably know you
know it's cool and fun and important but
if you don't know more than that here's
a good starting point so you should
think about machine learning algorithms
really as tools for finding patterns in
data and an easy way to talk about this
might be well I'm I've got a web store
and I've got customers and I collect
demographic information about these
customers and then I can apply a machine
learning algorithm to notice that there
might be clusters of similar customers
and maybe I want to market to these
customers slightly differently or maybe
I also collect information about what
they buy in my store and I can use
machine learning algorithms to make
predictions that help me you know make
more money in the future so I might see
that some customers buy one particular
type of music album for instance and
others buy another type of album and
when I see a new customer coming to my
store of course I I know lots about them
because I've been tracking them on the
Internet
I can say oh you're gonna like this
artist please buy this thing and they're
gonna buy it we can also use machine
learning algorithms to generate from
data to generate new similar content
this interestingly it's not that useful
for selling things to customers in this
way right I'm not going to generate new
virtual customers usually but it is
really fun with pictures of cats so
these are now just cats and with enough
pictures of cats and the right machine
learning infrastructure
can generate new pictures that are
similar and I will never run out of
pictures of cats on the Internet so
we've solved a big problem for humanity
of course you can do this with other
types of content and it starts to become
really fun one of my favorites is using
the same type of algorithm to generate
music album album covers you can do this
with video you can do this with audio
one of the now classic year old projects
in audio no is wavenet so this is the
same kind of algorithmic approach
roughly speaking but applied to a data
set which is a big collection of
classical piano music and so I'll play
you the results of what this generative
model produces so sounds like a piano
that's great you can do this with texts
one of my favorite people in the
internet right now is Janel Shayne
follow her on Twitter if you don't
because she's amazing and she does a lot
of creative projects finding text
corpora to model and then generate and
so this is Halloween costume names and
you can kind of see here it's learned
some things about what we like as people
for Halloween costumes there's a whole
sexy set of costumes and then it's you
know doing some things that you know you
could imagine someone dressing up as
that but maybe a person hasn't thought
of that before by the way I went on
Google Images and googled sexy lamp
today and this is the first results I'm
just gonna leave it at that you can buy
for 512 dollars so this isn't perfect
right this you're not gonna be fooled
that a sane human came up with this
content or you know put compose that
piano music trying to sound like Chopin
but these algorithms are gonna get
better and better and sooner or later
maybe next year the year after we're
just gonna have a button right where we
as creative people can say I want some
new content I'm gonna run this algorithm
and then be done all right so that's the
end of my talk right
and you're laughing right you're
laughing hopefully many of you are HCI
people and you might realize that this
is a little bit limiting and
short-sighted you'll notice first of all
my button has a couple asterisks there
the first caveat is that this works
really well if you have lots of data
right so this these algorithms don't
tend to work out of the box the way that
I've shown you when you have really
small data set so that limits a bit the
set of domains where you can apply these
as is it's also ideal to have a PhD a
lot of programming and math experience
to get these things working if you want
to do your own stuff with them but more
problematically if you don't like what
things spit out your option in many
cases is you kind of hit the button
again and so the interaction model here
if you think about how this is going to
be used to create new content is a
little bit limiting right it's a little
bit like hey you know you're doing a
creative thing let me make a creative
thing for you however you know so one of
the things I want you get to get out of
this talk today is maybe a bit more of a
critical eye when you see really
exciting funny machine learning systems
that are out there doing creative work I
think they can be interesting for all
sorts of reasons but that doesn't mean
that they're necessarily the right tools
for human creators and I also want to
get you thinking about how there are all
sorts of other opportunities both with
these generative methods and with other
types of methods to really support human
creators and really interesting exciting
ways so I've been doing research in this
area for about ten years now I'm really
interested in how machine learning can
be used not to really you know replace
people and give them this big red button
but to support people's existing
creative practices and so we can break
that down a bit using those definitions
of machine learning that I started with
at the beginning and we can ask when
might it be creatively useful to find
patterns and data to make predictions to
generate new similar examples and I'm
also really interested in making tools
so that creative practice
and different domains can use these
techniques effectively in their own work
because I think it's really
short-sighted in limiting if people with
engineering programming expertise are
the only ones who can use them we're
gonna end up with just less interesting
stuff for one thing so one key to
recognizing what all the opportunities
with machine learning might be is to
start by thinking about what might the
data be all right what kind of data
could we use to do these things and
they're potential sources of data
everywhere right a lot of the cool
generative modeling techniques have used
large datasets datasets large images
datasets and so on that either have you
know arisen on the internet or have been
carefully curated and yes those are
really exciting and they are really
useful often but there are other sources
of data that are often just as powerful
right data that you could collect from
sensors from cameras from microphones
about what people might be doing at this
moment how they're how they're moving
for instance or data that creators make
incidentally throughout their work right
if I'm doing photo editing the whole set
of photos that I've edited in the past
that's data the sequence of operations
that I do within the software as I work
that's data we could model that we could
find patterns and that that could be
really fun and then there's all sorts of
data that might not be inherently
creative but which we care about a lot
things like our social media data or the
weather people have been making music
and art out of these data sources for a
long time and machine learning gives us
some extra infrastructure for dealing
with that data and perhaps more useful
ways so let's just focus for the moment
on this prediction paradigm the same
type of algorithms that we can use to
predict which you know which album
someone's going to buy we can use that
in other contexts and for me I got
really interested in using machine
learning with sensors and with real time
interactions and so instead of saying
well here's demographic information
here's what they're going to want to
purchase we could say well maybe we're
going to listen to what sound is
happening in the world or what sound is
coming into a microphone and then use
that to drive some kind of
cuter action and maybe this is a music
visualization or maybe this is a voice
control game lots of different things
could fit into this paradigm or the
place that I really dug into when I was
a PhD student was this to say well what
if we take information from sensors that
give us data about how people are moving
and predict what sound we want the
computer to make right and we can use
this supervised learning infrastructure
to make some cool stuff so I'm now going
to give you a demo of the software that
I made starting in about 2008 to make it
easy for composers to build new musical
instruments with sensors and you can use
this in all sorts of other domains it's
been used in a lot of different projects
at this point but it gives you this
basic infrastructure where you start out
and say I'm going to capture some data
from the world or maybe read it from a
file but it's more fun if you're getting
it in real time sometimes and I'm gonna
send that to a predictive model and that
model is gonna give me some kind of
output that I can use to choose which
sound to play or control the parameters
of a synthesis algorithm or control how
a robot moves or whatever I want right
and this is modular this can be any
software on the bottom here and of
course more interestingly Weka nater
doesn't just limit you to taking someone
else's model that you know has been
trained by an expert to do a particular
thing it allows people even if they
don't have programming or machine
learning expertise to build that model
themselves so let's let's start out with
a demo so the first thing I'm going to
show you I like oops not that one I like
this example because I'm gonna run for
this first component the world's worst
computer vision system and we're still
going to be able to build something
useful with it so this is just taking my
webcam input chopping it into 10 by 10
grid cells and sending that data out as
a single flat vector so you know if
you're a programmer you even if you're a
really good programmer you're not gonna
be happy if I say you have to write some
code that looks at those hundred numbers
and says something useful about what's
happening in front of the camera you
might be able to do it but it would be
really annoying so instead I'm going to
I'm going to use supervised learning to
build a predictive model and I'm going
to build a classifier and I'm going to
use this classifier to control a drum
machine alright
and so I don't have a data set to start
with right there's no ground truth data
set of how I look in front of this
camera in this room to control the sound
but I can make that so I'm gonna start
out by saying I want this sound to
happen when I'm standing here and I've
just captured 15 examples that's it and
now maybe I want another sound to happen
when I'm not standing there and I'm
gonna train I'm gonna build a machine
learning model and I'm gonna run it and
see how it does ok so it's working
pretty well
and if I move around I can see well it's
making a mistake right here and that's
okay I can give it more examples and say
this this is still me now please run and
it's yeah maybe I want to fine-tune it
and say this is also still me and I just
keep iteratively improving the model by
adding some more data and if I'm happy
with it I can maybe make it more
complicated I could say well here's
another thing there's my hand okay so
that's building a classifier to control
sound pretty straightforward pretty easy
like as you can see I didn't need to
know much about machine learning to make
that work and it worked even though I
had really horrible data coming in I
want to give you another example of how
actually how most composers use this
when I started building this into a tool
for them in 2008-2009 and you know the
music that I was playing for you just
now you could play that same music with
a few buttons right it's creatively not
giving you lots of different musical
expressive possibilities however there
are lots of things that you know are
hard to control with buttons right if
you have lots of different parameters of
sound changing at once that
starts to become musically more of an
interesting possibility space so most
composers weren't using classification
like I just showed you most of them were
very interested in regression and
regression with multiple predicting
multiple continuous values at a time and
likewise most of them weren't using this
crappy webcam input they were interested
in using different kinds of sensors that
might get different information about
how people were moving or acting so here
I'm going to use the leap motion just
use the shape and position of my hand to
control some sound and I'm gonna open up
a fun little music program which is
going to allow me to do some
manipulation of an audio sample if it
loads there we go so I'm gonna okay so
there's my audio sample and I might say
I want to use my hands now to control
how this sample gets played back and
maybe when I put my hands a little
earlier there when I put my hand kind of
just a few inches above this I want this
normal sound to happen and maybe I want
the pitch to go up as I move my hand up
so I'll give some more examples with
that new position and that new sound and
now I have a continuous pitch controller
which is kind of fun and I can start
making this more interesting and say
maybe I also want different hand shapes
to really do crazy stuff to the sound so
maybe I want maybe I like that and I
want to sort of claw hand over here to
give me that sound and I can put that in
retrain with those additional examples
and that's kind of cool maybe I like
that but maybe I want to do some other
totally weird stuff like that's a neat
sound and maybe I'll put that over over
here somewhere alright so that's that's
you get the idea pretty easy to build a
new interaction that way so that's the
end of the first part of my talk does
anybody have any questions about what I
was doing right there
okay everybody more or less gets it if
you want to yeah yeah are using so this
this is a leap motion with my that was
the thing getting my hand so there you
buy them for 40 bucks or something
yeah yeah too many things which are
asleep lately lately you couldn't you
couldn't you leave me it's tell like you
have like a lot of things just don't
really not pitiful like they did it like
look what happens yes so you know there
all sorts of really interesting
questions here about you know certainly
different learning algorithms are going
to allow you to learn different things
and not others or might require
different amounts of data to learn
different things
the I can talk more about the details of
this and the question period but one of
the things that I did with Weka nater is
I the first version of this I built
using a set of really intense
participatory processes with composers
to try to figure out like what is a
reasonable default to put in there
that's going to be able to more or less
learn the stuff that I saw people doing
and so the hidden sauce under the hood
is the choice of algorithm and the
configuration of that and so I can I can
talk about that in more detail later if
you want
I've also been working with people
observing people using this software for
a long time now and continually kind of
trying to understand you know again what
is it that they're doing are the
configurations of defaults the way that
this is set up the number of models is
that a good match to what people really
want to do and how can we make it
better so actually that leads into the
second part of my talk which is really
not just how do we make stuff like Weka
nador that's usable that's part of it
but what do people use this for what is
it good for how might it support
different types of creative practices
and because I'm giving this talk into
computer science building today I've got
a little bit of stuff thrown in here
about how using machine learning in this
context to build things ends up looking
a little bit different from using
machine learning in more conventional
applications okay so I've got sort of
five really high-level research findings
that I want to throw at you and again we
can go into more detail of in any of
these in the question period if you want
so the first really exciting thing for
me when I started this work as a PhD
student was that people immediately
started using it to build really weird
stuff that I hadn't expected and
especially started building interactions
with sensors and so I want to give you a
couple examples so you can see that it's
not just like weird claw hands making
weird sounds there's actually you know
some really beautiful music that people
have made for instance this is a piece
by a composer Hugh
yeah she's using these controllers these
are actually playstation golf game
controllers but she's having people play
music with it I'll leave it at that and
should play the video for you oh no
go go away hold on I'm totally stuck
PowerPoint has frozen oh my gosh all
right we may never get out of this
presentation but that's okay there we go
here's Ann's piece
[Music]
so you'll notice a couple of things here
one of the reasons I really like this
piece is I mean the sound is lovely but
the experience of watching that piece
being performed is totally different
from watching someone you know doing
electronic music by standing in front of
a laptop and typing and using a mouse
and also the types of movements that she
wanted in this piece she wanted
performance to do something that's very
much like a yoga Sun Salutation sequence
she was able to build that pretty easily
with machine learning to say here's how
I want the performers to move here's how
the sound should change as they move
whereas that kind of instrument would be
a lot harder to build using programming
another one of my favorite really early
interfaces that somebody built was this
one it says Michelle Nunn guy who was a
composer who walked down the street one
day and saw a piece of tree bark and
said I need to turn this into a musical
instrument so she brought it home put
light sensors in the bark and built an
instrument that she plays by casting
shadows over these 25 or so light
sensors so again this is a really
beautiful instrument you can watch her
play it on Vimeo but it's an instrument
where it just wouldn't have been
feasible to build to get 25 kind of
weird noisy inputs that are also really
impacted by the lighting conditions in
the room and so on she was able to make
this quite easily with machine learning
since then people have been using Weka
Nader for all sorts of other kinds of
projects that I didn't envision which i
think is great this is an art project
featured in motherboard by a student who
you put a camera on your head and if
that camera detects something that looks
like a screen then it takes special
glasses that you're wearing and makes
them opaque so you cannot look at a
screen while wearing these glasses which
is pretty cool
I've also used what needed a lot of
teaching both teaching my students at
Goldsmiths and teaching interaction
design to people who may or may not be
you have done programming with sensors
before but also teaching workshops of
various other universities conferences
workshop locations and so on and a lot
the things that people have made end up
being just really fun and kind of
whimsical this is high but this is all
it does is you you wave to it waves back
and I like that you know for this the
hard part of this project was thinking
about what to do
gluing the servo motor behind the
cardboard and not actually saying well I
need to now figure out what is a wave
computationally and find that write the
code to identify that so there's lots of
other really cool projects that people
have done everything from sort of rock
pop music to puppetry to starting
companies with apps that you know react
to you in really intelligent ways and
I'll talk about some of the work I've
done in the accessibility space I could
give a whole talk on this I'm not going
to you can go on the Wacken ad website
or YouTube Vimeo and see some really
cool stuff but again lots lots of the
really fun projects are projects where
people are using sensors and making
things that might be really hard or at
least annoying and slow to make without
machine learning now the second point I
want to make is that building these
types of interactions with machine
learning especially building creative
interactions but even building things
that might be you know not very creative
requires a few differences in the
interface is that we give people and the
way that we think about the role of the
algorithms so in conventional machine
learning context the way that you would
learn about machine learning in a
computer science class usually the goal
of using machine learning is to build an
accurate model of your data so that
perhaps you can make predictions on new
unseen data in the future all right
super useful if you build that model it
doesn't work very well often you're
going to change the algorithm and find a
more suitable algorithm or you might
change the features or you might say oh
I've got more data that I can you know
collect and use a bigger data set that
might often help as well but you you
don't want to mess around with the data
too much because the data you talk about
it as a ground truth right it embodies
some sort of truth about the world that
you don't have access to other than
through the data when people are
creating in
interactions with machine learning a lot
of these things change right people
still might want to build a controller
that they would call accurate right
there's for instance if I want to build
a gaming controller that reacts to me
you know punching I wanted to always
react a hundred percent of the time and
not react otherwise but that accurate
controllers in the context of a larger
goal which is I want to play a game
that's fun that's accessible to people
that doesn't you know doesn't take
practice to learn how to use or maybe I
want to build an expressive musical
interface that gives me cool sounds that
I can play onstage without looking
stupid right there's all sorts of other
subjective complex goals here and
sometimes changing the algorithm or
features are really good ideas but often
changing the training data is the most
effective and reasonable way to change
what the model is doing if it's not
doing what you want so you saw that in
the the camera example right when I
found a place where it made a mistake I
was able to easily correct that by just
giving it examples I'm like oh I
overlooked what it might you know what I
should tell it to do when I'm standing
here so I can fix that and we retrain
and we're good and so in HCI people
people often talk about this as
human-in-the-loop approaches to machine
learning or interactive machine learning
machine learning researchers may mean
something slightly different when they
talk about interactive machine learning
and the reason that this makes sense
it's a complicated conversation but one
of the reasons is that this data often
yeah there may be some kind of hidden
truth in it that we can't articulate
otherwise but it's the data is really
sort of user interface or communication
channel between the person and the
machine right it's my first training set
is my way of telling the computer what I
want it to do and my subsequent training
sets might be refinements of that those
instructions about what I want it to do
and so this actually requires some
rethinking about what it is that we want
the algorithm to do what makes a good
algorithm and of course how we structure
the user interface right most other
software environments especially
software environments for
non-interactive not more conventional
machine-learning don't make it this easy
to mangle your training data because
that's a bad thing Weka Nader we you
know I learned right away that that was
gonna be super useful for people so we
need to have interfaces that allow the
kinds of manipulations that make sense
but this leads to some interesting
computational consequences in that you
know people are gonna provide training
data that is not iid right this is sort
of assumption that often we make for
convenience and maybe even with good
reason when we're talking about machine
learning theory but people turns out are
often smarter than that and if we allow
them to be smarter we take advantage of
the fact that they're smarter we can
learn more efficiently so let's imagine
we're building a musical instrument and
we're looking at maybe where my hand is
in space and I want one sound to happen
when my hand is in the purple and one
sound when my hand is in the orange if I
were doing this in a more traditional
machine learning context I might go out
and collect a bunch of data try to get
the best data set possible and get a
nice even sampling maybe from these two
regions and that would be a pretty good
if small data set when people are using
Weka Nader's to build examples even when
they don't know anything at all about
machine learning often they'll start by
giving just a few examples maybe in the
center of the purple in the center of
the orange more or less and they're not
going to spend too much time worrying
about it and then they'll build a model
and see where that decision boundary is
and if it's not exactly where they want
they're gonna add some corrective data
so they may say well this is really
purple and this is really orange and now
I'm gonna retrain and get my boundary
keep testing keep doing that but here
what I've done is I've learned
essentially the right decision boundary
but I didn't have to provide all these
other examples so it's kind of like the
same benefits that you would get from
active learning but here instead of the
algorithm saying hey please label these
unlabeled data points it's the person
just doing what they naturally do and
saying I'm gonna find where it makes a
mistake and I'm just gonna give
corrective examples there and of course
that only really works if you have an
algorithm that's perfectly willing to
trust that person and say yeah even if
you know even if that purple dot were
way over there maybe I trust you
and I'm gonna give you a super weird
decision boundary and do what we would
normally call overfitting turns out if
you try too hard not to over fit in many
of these interactive contexts people
take that sort of personally and they
say well the algorithms not listening to
me right I know what I'm doing and it's
still not doing what I want Oh another
consequence of building the interface
this way this was something that really
I hadn't thought about it all until I
started working with people and
observing how they were using the
software is that people were using this
these changes to the training data not
only to fine-tune the decision boundary
and correct mistakes but actually to try
out different hypotheses about what they
might build right so they might start
out with an idea the way that I did with
the leap motion and say well what if
what if I put this on here what if I put
this on there and as soon as I have that
then I've got a prototype and I can play
around with it and I can use my
experimentation with that right away to
say well was that a good idea or not and
if it was a good idea great maybe it was
a good idea but I found some other sound
in there that I really liked and I could
put that back in the data set or maybe I
didn't like it and so I can roll back
and so on right so we can think about
these changes to the data set as also
again people communicating hypotheses
about something that might be fun or
likewise people exploring and saying hey
I have an idea of the thing that might
be cool is this learn about is this
gonna be learn about given the fact that
I'm not willing to spend more than five
minutes giving training examples right
and people often are involved in this
negotiation with the algorithm to say
well what's the most useful thing I can
build in the amount of time that I have
so of course we can think about these as
all really valuable types of activities
in any kind of design context right
supporting rapid prototyping supporting
exploration recognizing the fact that
people are in a dialogue with the
materials that they're using and
allowing them to have that dialogue and
explore and experiment rather than
assuming that yo this is ground truth
training data and it's it's never going
to change so I did a project with a
student a few years ago exploring this
and saying well what if we were to make
user interfaces for design with machine
learning that
assume from the get-go that you're gonna
change your mind and make it easier for
you to reason about what alternative
designs might be good ones or might be
problematic and in the meantime also
make it possible to control sounds but
by beatboxing because that's fun in a
more serious long-term project that just
finished up I've been working with a
bunch of startups in music tech and
gaming around Europe and this project
was a three year effort called rapid mix
and we started out really recognizing
that using interactive machine learning
to build interactions is really powerful
it's powerful as a design tool but what
Commuter isn't for everybody right Weka
nadir is good for teaching it's good for
building musical instruments not so
great for software developers who want
to build their own app or want to build
their own game and so we started my
portion of the project started with
asking well what it might it look like
to build tools for developers that allow
them to engage in the same kind of
experimentation to build tools for
developers that they can use without
having to go take a machine learning
course first I don't think we've
answered all those questions these are
turns out the really difficult questions
but the current answer that we have is
embodied in this rapid mix API which you
can use in C++ or a couple other
environments open frameworks mechs MSP
if you're a programmer and you want to
do this kind of stuff in your own
projects yeah Michael yeah yeah so I
have a PhD student who's still got a
little bit of time left who was looking
at this and saying well you know clearly
we we don't have a guidebook that you
can use to write a good API there's lots
of you know research that's been done on
what makes API is understandable or
learn a bowl and we built on that but
machine learning is kind of its own
beast in some ways and so one of the
things that we were doing was developing
participatory processes to work with
developers as at these companies as well
as with creative coders and people at
hack days and so on to throw tools at
them and get feedback on them and kind
of build up a better understanding of
what is it that they're looking for
everything from really practical stuff
like which program
languages to even target to meet the
needs of this community to what ended up
being one of the most important
questions what do we need to teach
people about machine learning before
they start and can we make online
integrated tools where they have you
know some tutorial and a self
explanatory demo in the environment so
if you go to the website you know one of
the things that we did on the website is
have embedded code examples in
JavaScript so yeah we'll hopefully have
some more papers coming out about that
soon that we've got a short paper about
that right now all right next point I
want to make is that these tools ended
up when I asked folks that I was working
with you know why are you using machine
learning often it wasn't the answers
that I just started with it wasn't
answers about well I have sensors and
they're complex and I can't build
something otherwise often it was about
the way that they were able to think
when they were engaged in designing
interactions so the people using what
cañedo are often you know people who are
making music or who are moving or
thinking about sound or animation and
even if they're really good coders they
find that there's you know there's a
challenge in moving from thinking about
how you want to move or how you want
something to sound to turning that into
a mathematical equation and if we can
give people example based programming
interfaces then they don't have to make
that cognitive leap back and forth which
slows them down and gives them stuff
that they're less happy with so I want
to mention not just you know this is
something that's been important not just
in the Weka nater project but in several
other projects I've done with students
this idea of how data can provide a
foundation for building computer systems
that understand something that we are
doing some something that we're bodily
engaged with this led my former PhD
student Reid Oda to do a really cool
project recognizing that if we look at
how a percussionist is moving a
drumstick over time we can actually
predict pretty accurately when the next
drum beat is going to happen even if
they're not playing at a steady tempo
and we can take this information and
maybe send it over a network before that
hit happens and enable completely
latency free collaborative performance
so I can be hitting my drum in New York
and somebody in Tokyo can hear a sound
of that drum synthesized in exactly the
same time even if the network is
introducing some you know speed of light
delay in the best case so that was a
cool project last thing I want to say
about sort of my research findings is
that there's a whole space that I'm
excited about right now looking at how
machine learning does change people's
possibilities for creative practice
right so far I've been talking about how
it supports things that people naturally
do sort of with any medium but there are
things that I think machine learning
makes it easier to do that change
people's relationships with their tools
and some of these are potentially very
powerful now a lot of the tools out
there that are getting media attention
or you know going viral on social media
are really tools that make it easier for
people without expertise in some domain
to generate content in that domain and
there are some commercial products now
arising in this space this is duke deck
this is a london-based music tech
startup where you can make a song by
choosing what genre what mood duration
when you want the climax of the piece to
happen and then it'll make you a song
with with a name as well
and so here I'll play you this is my
aggressive synth pop track that it made
for me
[Music]
okay so you you know go try this out
this is free to try I'm not gonna
torture you with the rest of this track
it's not the worst music in the world
it's definitely not the best music in
the world so this again I I don't think
anybody's really you know thinks that
this is going to replace human composers
so I wouldn't say that it's a tool for
creativity in that way however I think
this is an awesome tool for YouTube
video creators who might not be
composers might not have the money to
hire a band or you know pay for the
rights to a particular track this allows
them to put original music in their
video without having expertise and
probably come up with a slightly better
end result right so they're delegating
something that isn't really central to
their to their goals and isn't really
matched to their expertise they're
delegating that to a computer and I
think that's that's useful there are a
lot of other kind of tools out there
this is edges to cats this one allows
you to sketch sort of a line drawing and
it'll fill it in with the closest thing
to a cat and again I think the target
you know I don't see this exact thing
being very useful to professional
artists but I probably we're gonna see
other tools that allow similar it
similar types of interaction which might
actually add value and actually I want
to skip over to this this is the smile
vector so this is somebody using deep
learning based approaches to make random
people on the Internet and historical
figures smile
right and this again this is kind of
cute but this is useful right if you say
I want to manipulate content maybe I'm a
professional artist or graphic designer
and I want to manipulate content in a
believable way this gives me a set of
tools to maybe let make my life easier
make me you know able to do more things
more flexibly back to the edges to
Katz's thing and what I do want to say
there is very interesting work being
made with this not to make cats
but to make other things so you know you
Batman Batman cat and and really a lot
of my favorite work my favorite creative
work with machine learning on the
Internet
I enjoy because it's people really
taking advantage of the ways that these
algorithms break down and exploiting
that in creative ways right so the the
machine isn't being particularly
creative here but the people are saying
hey I can appropriate this and do
something with this but you know if you
wanted to make a serious artist
statement you could say something
halfway reasonable about how this is a
commentary on human and machine
creativity and collaboration or
something or you know maybe it's just
Batman there are other artists doing
really you know serious work with
machine learning and if you talk to them
or study the ways that they're using
these tools it is often quite different
from using programming or using analog
materials so this is one of my favorite
artists Mario Clingerman he uses neural
nets to make visual art he's also a very
gifted programmer does all the technical
stuff himself as well so arguably a lot
of his art making is acting as a
programmer but he's got neural network
based systems that give him lots and
lots of different content and when he's
making work he also he made himself a
tinder like interface to sort of swipe
right or left based on whether the thing
he liked the thing that came out right
so he's at least in part of his art
practice now acting as a curator rather
than as you know the person deciding
which you know which color goes where
one of the musicians I've worked with
for a long time now who I've learned a
lot from is somebody named Leticia
tsunami and she's been using Weka nater
for about six years and she is very
critical of this idea that when we make
creative tools that they should be tools
that always do you know they allow us to
most efficiently impart our commands to
them and they follow our orders right
she she says in a way you don't want the
instrument to perform like a well
trained animal circus you want it to be
a little wild you want to adapt to it
somehow like riding a bull I think the
machine learning allowed more of this
fun of exploring instead of going I have
to have a result right away and then
this thing is going to do that and
leaving it at that right and again I
think lots of artists engage in you know
different work with different media will
say if they're speaking honestly that
the work that they make isn't always
just that they had a brilliant idea and
then they were able to use their expert
skill to make that idea right people
often get inspired by things that happen
with the materials that they're working
with that they didn't expect but which
they know to take advantage of and
incorporate into the final piece and
again I think some of the the nature of
the mistakes or oddities that you can
find in machine learning may make these
surprising push backs from the
algorithms more fruitful than perhaps
when you're coding and the surprise is
that you get a compiler error right
which is not likely to be creatively
enriching so have another side project
with a student where we said well what
what might it look like to make these
interactive interfaces where instead of
trying to use machine learning anything
resembling the right way what if we just
trying to make something that always is
going to surprise you where you grab a
sensor you move it around and then it
makes you a mapping so that was a fun
project all right so for the last few
minutes I want to talk about what I've
been thinking about in the space of
using machine learning to improve
inclusion and access and also improving
inclusion in terms of who gets to use
machine learning who gets to talk about
it and so on
and in a lot of my work one of the
exciting outcomes that I've you know
tried to focus on and learn from and do
more of is looking at how machine
learning can enable more people to be
creators so I do a lot of workshops
these are high school students for
instance who didn't know about machine
learning didn't know how to code didn't
know anything about computer music and I
was able to get them building computer
music instruments in an hour or so and
then later that afternoon they taught
the eight-year-olds in the classroom
next to them how to build things and
this is exciting right
and arguably a lot of the tools that you
see online things like edges to cats or
neural doodle they also allow more
people to become creators but I want to
again caution that I don't think that's
where the creative value of these
systems is because often the ways that
these system use data are to give you
good training wheels or guardrails and
they're going to say well we assume that
you want to have some kind of you know
typical realistic output and we're going
to give you that for free but they don't
give you a lot of ability to say well no
that's not what I want I want something
that's totally different and my own so I
think the space of interactive machine
learning whether that's iteratively
changing tradit training data or giving
people other ways of influencing what an
algorithm does and how have the
potential to be much more flexible and
and also allow people to personalize
systems and new ways so I have a project
finishing up right now with a bunch of
music therapists you wanted to use Weka
nater style interactive machine learning
to build musical instruments and we've
got a an open-source project here we're
going to release the final version next
week and this has been super fun they're
building instruments for kids who cannot
play most acoustic instruments and more
interesting than that they're not just
building personalized instruments that
are playable they're actually developing
a curriculum that takes advantage of the
fact that they now can make a new
interaction with sensors and sound in
about 30 seconds and so they often make
many interactions for different reasons
in the context of a session with a kid
or a classroom teaching session I've got
a current project with Microsoft
Research which I can't say much about
yet but we're looking at a lot of these
techniques in non musical contexts
saying how could we enable people who
are blind and visually impaired to
customize personalized computer vision
systems to get information that they
really care about from the world around
them and so these projects have really
gotten me thinking a lot about how how
this work might be in dialogue with
what's in the news recently right most
people in the world when they experience
data and machine learning it's as people
whose data is being sold or they're
being disempowered or they're being
manipulated by it
and I've been starting to think about
this question you know what can we do as
computer scientists or HCI researchers
or designers to make people's
experiences with data machine learning
less disempowering because there are all
these other ways to make you know to
give people value from data that they
create what what if we were able to give
people more value from their social
media data or their other data for
instance and how can we get more people
involved in the conversation about how
they want machine learning to be used
when it comes to their lives so in this
vein I've been involved increasingly in
machine learning education efforts I've
had a MOOC online for about three years
now exploring how we teach machine
learning to creative practitioners and
that's been super fun
I'll give you hints it's different from
how I would teach it to a computer
science class and it might actually look
really similar to how I would teach
machine learning to a non creative group
of people from the general public as
well and in fact if you haven't seen
Google's teachable machine demo you
should go look at that they explicitly
modeled this cool web app on the
interaction that wreckin aider gives you
but you don't have to download anything
it's just a website where you can go and
understand what supervised learning is
doing and make cool interactions with it
so I think there's a lot of space to
explore you know both how creative
applications of machine learning might
be useful in teaching people about what
these algorithms really do how they
break down but also thinking about for
instance how applications of machine
learning that foregrounds the impact of
choice of training data in the output of
the model how that might be used to
inform conversations about algorithmic
bias for instance the last thing I want
to mention is that I recently learned
about a really cool project in LA which
I had nothing to do with but they used
Weka nater in their work they're running
a bunch of workshops with folks around
LA to build new technologies and learn
about machine learning and especially
teach people who are not computer
scientists or not in the tech industry
people from various community groups
lots of them women to teach people about
what machine learning is and allow them
to build things that you know
accomplish something that's important to
them so one of the things they built was
a virtual protest environment for people
who couldn't you know leave their homes
because of disability or carrying
responsibilities and so on this allowed
them to actually interact with this
virtual environment together so that's
called post human AI so check that out
as well so with that I am happy to take
any questions but any of the stuff that
I talked about and if you again if you
want to build some stuff with me
tomorrow morning at 9:30 you should come
along you can also download what cañedo
for free at that website
[Applause]
yes created based on other music we
already know and we're like that's not
really interesting and I think that the
cultural critic would say well this has
other kinds of think of ways brilliant
or genius yeah so do you think that
would limit us ever in laughs it seems
as if we were to use current and now
technologies we would always we would
always need a human being because we
didn't know what is new persistent
that's a good question I mean I would I
would have challenged that just a little
bit I think the it was the dupe tech
stuff that you're talking about I think
my beef with the Juke back Juke Dec song
is not that it's not new it's that it
actually feels a little bit off to me as
a musician it's it's new in a way that
isn't how a human would do something new
and again I think that's gonna get
better
that said even in the current Juke tech
system there's a lot of human
infrastructure and human expertise
that's gone into you know how to set
that up and it's not just you know a
standalone machine learning algorithm
that's spitting out stuff there's all
sorts of human heuristics and
constraints that are built in and that's
the smart way to do it you know I think
there's that's that's gonna always be
part of the system as far as I can see
into the future because why wouldn't you
do that if you're trying to make money
and make stuff that's actually sound
good yeah I mean I do want to be clear
that the developers I was working with
that I have worked with are primarily
they consider themselves to be like
creative coders or they're working in
creative industries making apps or sound
stuff so it's not like they're making
finance apps or something so yeah it's a
good question not the question anybody's
asked me before so thank you I think
you know in workshops in both cases my
my learning goals for people have often
been you know I need to get it clear
like what is what is the workflow of
machine learning what is what is the
basic model of what we're doing and
that's you know I show that to you kind
of early on in the slides and that the
simplest way to express this is you've
got some inputs coming in and then
you've got a trained mom you've got some
outputs coming out and the other thing
that I tend to talk about with people or
put in educational materials before a
workshop is that you know this model you
would normally you write code to make
that input to output function but
instead we're gonna build that with
examples and so that's that's the place
that I start whether I'm working with
developers or whether I'm working with
you know fifteen-year-old kids or you
know with Weka Nader or whoever and
that's you know people usually don't
come with that knowledge already so I
think that's one of the things that
we've learned is not even about how to
pitch that to developers versus other
people but how to do that kind of
education about really functionally what
what are these algorithms going to be
good for and how do you embed them in an
architecture of a larger system because
what I want to do is get people to the
point point where they can quickly
imagine what they might build with that
and getting people to imagine things
that are feasible is really challenging
in both those circumstances and I think
probably more so with developers right
when I'm running a workshop with
creative artists and so when I give them
a lot of examples to work with but you
know developers I give them example code
but they suddenly you know they know
they can push that into a domain that
they're more familiar with but they
don't have an intuition about like what
features might be good how do I test
this algorithm you know do I is this
something I can do unit testing with and
so on there's a lot you know their
expertise means that they're asking
really hard questions much sooner in
some sense so education educational
materials interspersed with our API
documentation have just been really
really important debugging
create a model in what you need or you
can obviously just add more creating
examples do you try to do anything
explicitly to like help people real able
data that might be labeled yeah so not
in not in the regular Weka Nader
interface and that's something that the
the beatbox project we started thinking
about like how might you help people
notice that some of their data overlaps
in the feature space right which might
be indicative that it's mislabeled or
that the way that they've defined their
classes is inherently problematic given
the features that they have so I in the
regular Weka Nader application I haven't
done that for various various reasons
but if you haven't if you haven't looked
at care Patel's work for instance I mean
he's he explored that in more
conventional application context with
software developers and I think James
worked with him on that a bit so that's
you know I really found that work
inspiring and I think there's there's
lots more to do there and and more than
people at various companies now are
thinking about how to build into their
machine learning tools
[Applause]
you